if you were to run program analysis on
your own life how did you do in terms of
correctness running time resource use
asymptotically speaking of course okay
yeah well I would say that question has
not been asked me before and i i i
started out with library subroutines and
and learning how to be a automaton that
was obedient and i had the great
advantage that i didn't have anybody to
blame for my failures if I started
getting not understanding something I I
knew that I should stop playing ping
pong and that was that into it it was my
fault that I was that I wasn't studying
hard enough or something rather than
that somebody was discriminating against
me in some way and and I don't know how
to avoid this the existence of biases in
the world but i but i but i know that
that's an extra burden that i didn't
have to suffer from and and and then i I
found the from from parents I learned
the idea of of altruist to other people
as being more important than then when I
get out of stuff myself I you know that
I need to I need to be happy enough
enough in order to be able to speak up
service but I thought but I you know but
I I came to a philosophy for finally
that that I phrased as point eight is
enough
there was a TV show once called hate is
enough which was about a you know
somebody had eight kids but but I I say
point a is enough which means
if I could have a way of rating
happiness I think it's good design that
to have to have an organism that's happy
about 80% of the time and if it was 100
percent of the time it would be like
every like everybody's on drugs and and
never and and and and it everything
collapses nothing works because
everybody's just too happy do you think
you've achieved that point eight optimal
work there are times when I when I'm
down and I you know and I think I mean I
know that I'm chemically because I I
know that I've actually been programmed
to be I to be depressed a certain amount
of time and if that gets out of kilter
and I'm more depressed and you know
sometimes like like I find myself trying
to see now who should I be mad at today
there must be a reason why I'm but but
then I realize you know it's just my
it's just my chemistry telling me that
I'm supposed to be mad at somebody and
so and so I trigger Dobby I'll go to
sleep and get better but but if I'm but
if I'm not a hundred percent happy that
doesn't mean that I should find somebody
that that screaming and try to Sasson
but I'd be like I'm saying you know okay
I'm not a hundred percent happy but but
I'm happy enough to die to be a you know
part of a sustainable situation so so
that's kind of the numerical analysis I
do
if you converge towards the outcome in
life is a point eight
you